- [Voiceover] Hello
grammarians, David here
along with my cousin Beth who
also happens to be a teacher.
Say hello to the people Beth.
- [Voiceover] Hi people.
- [Voiceover] So today we
are going to talk about
sentence fragments, and
Beth you cover these
in classes that you teach.
Could you tell me please,
what is a sentence fragment?
- [Voiceover] Great.
A sentence fragment is when
a student writes a sentence
and they think it's a sentence,
but it's one that tells
maybe what happens,
but doesn't include who,
or it might include who
but doesn't tell what happens.
- [Voiceover] So sentence fragments
don't tell the whole story.
The way I would put it, is that a fragment
is a piece of a sentence
that cannot stand on its own,
but nevertheless, incorrectly
ends with a period.
So the whole story, for
instance, would be a fragment.
This is a fragment.
It could be a sentence but
it's missing something.
Beth, what is it missing, what
is the whole story missing?
- [Voiceover] Well we've got a subject
but we don't have what we
would call a predicate,
in other words, so we're giving a subject,
but we're not telling what
happens to that subject.
- [Voiceover] All right, so,
the whole story began 10 years ago.
And now we've got our subject
here, the whole story,
and now we've given it a predicate.
Similarly, if we just had this predicate,
and we just said it began ten years ago,
oh, that's not enough
to be a sentence either,
that's also a fragment.
Because now we've got a
predicate but no subject.
- [Voiceover] Right, we're telling about
something but we don't know what.
- [Voiceover] So in
order to be a sentence,
you need to have both a
subject and a predicate.
So you need to have a thing, like a noun,
or a pronoun, and then you
have to have something happen
to that noun or pronoun,
or something performed
by that noun our pronoun.
Right so, like the pancakes,
period, is not a sentence.
But the pancakes were delicious, is.
- [Voiceover] So you've
got a part that names,
that's your subject, and
then you've got the part
that finishes the thought,
that's your predicate.
- [Voiceover] Let's
look at another example.
All right, what about
because of the snowstorm?
Is that a sentence, Beth?
- [Voiceover] Nope.
- [Voiceover] Why not?
- [Voiceover] Well you
don't tell what happened
because of that snowstorm.
- [Voiceover] So this is
what we call, not even a,
I mean it's not even a
dependent clause, right?
It, this thing doesn't
have, doesn't really have
a subject or a verb.
It's really just a prepositional phrase.
So because of the snowstorm
something could happen,
but we don't know what that is, so,
because of the snowstorm,
we stayed home from school.
So we've got this sentence here,
this independent clause, right.
We stayed home from school.
And that's a subject and a predicate.
And if it were just stayed
home from school, period,
that wouldn't be a sentence.
And if it were just we, period,
that also wouldn't be a sentence.
And if it were just because
of the snowstorm, period,
that wouldn't be a sentence.
It doesn't have enough
support to stand on its own.
But all together, because
of the snowstorm, comma,
we stayed home from school, period.
That is a sentence.
So in order to make sure that
you're building sentences
you have to make sure that what you've got
is a subject and a predicate.
You gotta have a subject and
a verb, put 'em together,
slap on a period, you've got a sentence.
- [Voiceover] You've got some
good sentences there David.
- [Voiceover] You can learn anything.
David out.
- [Voiceover] And Beth out.